Hoy es 7 de agosto de 1996, el sobreviviente es el Sr. Isaac Reis, la entrevistadora es
Julia Abram, nacida en Caracas, el país Venezuela, y el idioma es español.
Mi nombre es Julia Abram, J-U-L-I-E-a-b-r-a-m. Hoy es 7 de agosto de 1996 y estoy conduciendo
la entrevista con el Sr. Isaac Mayer Reis en la ciudad de Caracas y el país Venezuela.
Correcto.
¿Cómo se llama usted?
A-J-Z-Y-K. Es como un cédulo, ¿no? Era A-I-S.
¿Cómo se lee?
Reis.
¿Y el nombre?
Isaac, el cédulo. El nombre de mi mamá es O-P-O-O-L, sobol.
¿Y?
Y, el nombre llamado para eso ahora, Isaac Mayer Reis.
¿Cómo me deletrea Mayer?
Mayer. M-E-I-E-R.
¿Usted tiene algún otro nombre?
No.
¿Y algún sobrenombre?
No tengo más nombres. Esos son dos nombres que tengo.
¿Y acá lo llaman de una forma diferente?
Me llaman por asunto que sobreviví en la guerra, que no podía llamarme Isaac Reis o Mayer.
Era peligroso. Me llamaron Adam.
¿Me lo puede deletrear, por favor?
A-D-A-N, Adam. Reis, R-A-I-S.
¿En qué fecha nació usted?
El 20 de marzo de 1912.
¿Qué edad tiene hoy?
El 20 de marzo de 1997 voy a cumplir 85 años.
¿Y hoy cuántos años tiene?
84.
¿Y en qué ciudad y qué país nació?
En Ciudad Vlodava, Nadbugiem.
Vlodava, Nadbugiem.
¿Por qué se escribe Nadbugiem?
Ciudad era al lado de un buque, se llama, que tiene 2720 metros de largo y 1200 metros de ancho.
¿Y en qué país nació?
Vlodava.
¿Y el país?
Polonia.
¿Cómo era Vlodava?
Vlodava era una ciudad muy bella, linda.
Era muy religioso.
Era un gran sinagoga.
No tengo que explicar, ya usted lo vio en la foto.
En este sinagoga entraron hasta 8000 personas.
Allá, aparte de este sinagoga, que era, eran muchos sinagogas pequeños.
La región es una región en el mundo.
La región está dividida.
Hay sabios de la guerra.
Sabios de la guerra.
Entonces, cada sabio rabino tenía su gente creyente en él.
Por esto eran pequeños sinagogas.
No religión, igual.
Entonces, se llama idealismo.
¿Cómo era la comunidad judía, además de tantos sinagogas?
Era muy unido.
¿Qué era?
En esta ciudad era especial una caja de oro.
Cuando eran gente, tú sabes que siempre que empezó el mundo, que sigue el mundo,
hay pobres, hay millonarios y hay ricos.
Los ricos se juntaron con millonarios, hicieron una caja de oro,
y cuanto, por ejemplo, que vino un señor que yo no tengo,
yo quiero hacer algo para ganar pan para mis hijos,
prestaron el dinero sin interés, para un año sin interés.
Que él vino el año que no podía pagar, hicieron otro año prólogo.
Esta caja siempre creció.
¿Por qué creció?
Que cada uno hizo abono para la caja, tal, tal, tal, tal.
No puede ahorita usted decir que abonaron 10 lotes,
porque la moneda allá se llamaba lote, o 20 lotes.
La caja siempre creció y siempre era para todo el mundo que vino.
Flodava tenía necesidad, era brazo abierto y con cariño recibido.
Era una junta colectiva, ayudaba mucho a las gentes pobres.
Flodava tenía una gran fama.
Usted sabe que Flodava era pequeño Gdansk.
¿Qué significa pequeño Gdansk?
Era el más grande aeropuerto en Polonia, que ya salieron por todo el mundo.
Ahora Gdansk era export.
Flodava hizo más export que todas las ciudades de Polonia,
porque en un tiempo era un gran haciendado.
Se llamaba Javier Zamolski.
¿De dónde viene ese nombre Javier Zamolski?
Era un tiempo en el mundo que de muchas ciudades que tenía gran parte del mundo.
Y él tenía bosques muy grandes.
Aquí en Venezuela, en todo el mundo, no se ven árboles, aparte que existen en Rusia.
Un árbol tenía 25 ó 30 metros de altura y derechito.
Este árbol se dividía en tres partes.
¿Qué significan tres partes?
Un parte número uno, un parte número dos, un parte número tres.
Parte uno era para export, mejor clase de madera.
Y esto, cuando yo me puse mayor, era mi profesión.
¿Cómo era su familia? Cuéntenme un poquito cómo se llamaban sus padres.
Mi padre se llamaba Samuel Reis.
Mi padre viene de una familia muy religiosa.
Mi padre era uno de los más jóvenes de sus hermanos,
con lo cual yo era el más joven de mis hermanos y de sus hermanos.
Mi mamá se llamaba Ana Sobol.
Ella vino de Brest-Litovsk, otro lado de Bok.
Mi padre vivía en este lado de Bok.
¿Qué era el Bok?
12.720 metros por 1.020 metros de ancho.